what's up fellow geeks it's ineo and
today we have the nothing one this thing
runs a snapdragon 778 g plus and it's
gpus and adreno 642l we're going to run
the big three we're going to run kenshin
apex and call of duty mobile on this
thing and we'll see how it goes it's a
really unique looking phone and i
honestly can't wait to game with it so
let's go
[Music]
and before we get into the test we're
going to be checking the temperature on
the back of the phone
so you guys roughly know where it stands
it's relatively cool right now below 30
degrees celsius so it's doing pretty
much fine
currently this is running at the
recommended settings but we're going to
try to bump it up and go to the highest
settings for everything and see how well
this thing runs
so first things first we're going to
head into the settings
so it's low on default we're gonna push
to the highest set things and if we see
any like major
uh frame jumps or stuttering or anything
like that we're gonna change it back to
low or medium at least to see what works
best for this phone
highest high tires fps put it 60
uh
yeah
right
let's restart the game real quick
so we're going to start off in monster
as usual because you know it's quite
densely populated with npcs and a lot of
people experience major frame rate jobs
here but so far it's working out fine
though i do feel like the top up where
the camera is at heating up a little bit
but it's not that bad
yeah it jumped to like 33
from 28 ish just now so that's a major
but that's to be
expected as well from this phone or
rather just any phone running engine
so let's just move around a little bit
oh yep yeah you saw that
yeah little frame jarring right there a
little stuttering here and there but
that's to be expected as well we are
running an adrenal 642l
and obviously compared to like the other
gaming phones we reviewed recently such
as the asus rog phone 6 pro and the
blackjack 5 pro
the engineer 642l kind of pales in
comparison to the gpu that they're using
and even the cpu that they're using
which are the snapdragon 8 plus and the
8 so
yeah but so far it's running fine ish
let's teleport somewhere
somewhere nice and scenic would be good
all right teleportation let's see how
long it takes
oh okay it's not bad
okay let's find some enemies
to fight
yeah okay
yeah you guys can see the frame it drops
here and there but like
this is on the highest so you got to
give you got to cut the
nothing one a bit of slack
[Applause]
[Music]
but so far open worldwide you know with
a small number of enemies it's okay
considering the range of this phone it's
a mid-range phone so it's holding up
pretty well
the chipset which i believe is actually
near the camera is
heating up a little bit more compared to
just now
yeah it went up
so let's just go to the abyss and get
into an actual fight
and see how this thing runs
all right let's go
so just a little bit of rain something
there again
but honestly it's holding up to the high
settings pretty well actually a lot
better than i expected
so
yeah okay
changing it pretty okay
i mean you do get you do see a little
bit of frame something here and there
but other than that it's running fine
[Applause]
it's not that bad
wow okay
yeah
okay let's just check out the back after
the whole session
oh it's handling heat really well
actually
they're the black shark five pro
which was compared to the asus rog phone
six pro
this thing is actually handling it
pretty well pretty okay i mean obviously
he doesn't have the processing power of
the blackstar 5 pro but given its price
range and its specs it's actually
handling pretty well it's really
comfortable to play at especially on the
more demanding games so
ah
okay
that's pretty high huh
temperature wise we are at the whopping
37
right so i guess this is where the chip
is at so it's about 37 degrees right now
which honestly isn't too bad
considering how high the black shark
went to so yeah here we go
i've set everything to the highest
already extremely high extreme hd
uh we're all good
yup okay bloom on reflection quality
reflection quality is on
dynamic shadows confirmed okay yeah so
this is all on everything's on high
right now
my name is ray
and we have a job to do oh yep see that
[Applause]
okay
you just kind of bring me dropped a
little bit on the character screen so
yeah it's all right
korean drops in the menus screen jobs
correct the screen and yep it really
drops here as well
[Music]
oh and break off
stay close to dark if you're hurting
yeah play on this thing so far feels all
right no it's actually a very nice size
to get around the controls and navigate
the ui
so so far so good
okay let's change it up for the g7
[Applause]
yep one down
where's the other dude
oh yeah pretty job there again
good execution yeah even during the
execution
oh yeah okay yeah
[Applause]
[Applause]
you went
wow
so as you see like during combat the
frame rate does drop at unfortunate
times especially when you
really acquire the target but
i guess we'll get i guess like so far
it's working pretty okay given that this
is patching myself given that we are on
the high settings so
yeah
wow
why is my why does my rf301 sound like
that
is cause it's a lag or something or huh
and also first i'm getting knocked down
in apex that's an achievement
so yeah even
thing the frame rate does drop a lot and
i think this is cute for me to play call
of duty and see what happens next
[Applause]
and so far
yep 38 degrees
which honestly isn't that bad
i gotta go check factors black shark
temperatures again but you know
yeah but you know what for its specs and
everything it's doing pretty alright so
let's move on to call of duty
okay
graphics
max frame rate max graphic quality says
multiplayer settings everything is on
boom as well let's restart the game and
see
how it goes
so far the whole thing is working really
smoothly oh and before that let's check
the temperatures again
it's still riding off the last one but
it went down quite a bit by like three
degrees four degrees ish
so
let's just game
yeah little frame something here
[Applause]
there's nothing happening
on the enemies it's
running all right actually
all the games look really good on the
phone so far and the sound is actually
pretty all right
so let's just
keep playing onto the wrong end and
let's see how the spares are temperature
wise
[Applause]
[ __ ]
[Applause]
[Applause]
inside
[Applause]
okay so actually that was pretty good uh
the phone doesn't feel warm at all
so let's just check it out
yeah it actually is reduced in
temperature by a bit i could actually
went up a little bit
on the top here
but like if you buy like a degree or two
but but it feels comfortable to play
with so
let's just move on to our final thoughts
then
i was expecting a lot less with the
nothing one or that i wasn't expecting
much of anything because you know it's
not exactly a gaming centric phone given
its cpu and gpu and the price point and
yada yada but
this thing has held this up pretty well
in terms of heat management and how it
handles higher graphical set things on
say these games especially genji and
apex
but given as well that you know this
phone's uh specs are meant to handle
stuff at the lower to mid graphical
settings but on the higher ones you know
you can push this thing a little bit but
expect frame drops and stuttering to
happen pretty often but honestly not as
often as i thought it would happen the
nothing was actually pretty okay as a
gaming phone if you have any questions
about the phone leave them in the
comment section down below and i'll do
my best to get to them and if you like
this video consider following all of our
socials like this video and subscribe to
us that helps us out a lot we have a lot
of content coming your way on the
regular
and that's it this is ineo and i'll chat
with you guys soon take care so if you
guys love this phone you definitely love
our other videos and they're right here
like here just click it
come on
you know you wanna
come on dude i do that i do them let's
go